Trascrizione: Giulia Sgarbossa
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Tutti noi siamo consapevoli un po’
di quello che è successo.
A novembre c’è stata
una conferenza molto importante
in cui si è discusso
quali sono le strategie
per la riduzione delle emissioni,
e una parte consistente
della discussione è stata dedicata,
come si vede qui, anche alle foreste.
Perché, in linea di principio, le foreste
dovrebbero essere in grado di assorbire
parte dell’anidride carbonica
emessa dalle attività umane
e quindi ridurre questo
continuo aumento che registriamo
nella concentrazione
dell’anidride carbonica nell’atmosfera.
Si è talmente tanto discusso di foreste,
con anche stanziamenti
molto consistenti, come avete visto,
per le nuove foreste,
per evitare la deforestazione,
che i giornali ovviamente
se ne sono occupati
e hanno prodotto anche
delle prime pagine molto interessanti.
Questa è di un quotidiano del 3 novembre,
con un titolo provocatorio
e anche ironico,
che vi invito a commentare insieme.
Qual è secondo voi il significato profondo
di questo titolo?
Qual è la vostra opinione?
Cosa vuol dire?
(Risposte indistinte dal pubblico)
Interpretazione assolutamente insolita,
io non l’avevo intesa così.
Proviamo a vedere
se c’è qualche altra idea.
Io l’avevo interpretata invece, come...
(Risposte indistinte dal pubblico)
Sì, ma viene data talmente
tanta importanza alle foreste,
che le foreste magiche ci risolveranno
tutto il problema dell’anidride carbonica.
Allora proviamo a vedere un po’
di cosa si tratta.
Qui vi ho riassunto alcuni titoli
di altri articoli su questo argomento.
Guardiamoli.
Riscaldamento globale:
gli alberi rilasciano più CO2
di quella che assorbono.
Addirittura questo sarebbe il contrario.
Surriscaldamento globale:
piante e suolo assorbono sempre meno CO2.
Qui c’è un aspetto anche in più,
c’è qualcosa che sta cambiando.
Le piante assorbono CO2,
però coi cambiamenti climatici
forse non lo faranno più.
Oppure: piantare nuovi alberi serve
a contrastare i cambiamenti climatici?
Domandona.
È quello che vorremmo
cercare di capire oggi.
Piantare alberi può salvare il clima.
Simile a questa, ma vedete che qua
c’è un po’ di confusione,
ci sono temi diversi,
prospettive diverse, ecc.
Quello che vogliamo fare oggi
è provare a districarsi un po’
in questo argomento
e mettere qualche punto fermo
che ci possa aiutare a capire
cosa effettivamente sta succedendo.
Per fare questo dobbiamo fare un po’
un salto alle basi dell’ecologia
e del funzionamento della foresta.
Molto semplice, però sono quelle basi
che ci consentono
di fare qualche ragionamento.
Chiedo scusa se c’è qualche biologo,
perché ripeto cose molto semplici.
Allora, la foresta è un ecosistema,
quindi è un sistema integrato
costituito da varie componenti.
Alcune componenti sono le piante,
una componente importantissima,
fondamentale sono le piante,
e le piante hanno questa
grande capacità magica,
scusate no, non è magica ovviamente,
di assorbire l’anidride
carbonica dall’atmosfera.
Quindi, con il processo di fotosintesi,
la CO2 che è in atmosfera
viene incamerata in composti
che sono sostanzialmente quelli
su cui voi siete seduti, cioè il legno.
Lì dentro c’è l’anidride carbonica
che era in atmosfera prima
ed è stata trasferita nel legno.
Contemporaneamente, però,
a questo processo di assorbimento,
vedete è in verde,
quindi vuol dire che la CO2 viene estratta
dall’atmosfera e immessa nel sistema,
c’è anche un processo antagonista
che è la respirazione
per cui anche le piante
respirano ovviamente,
come sanno le nostre nonne, che ci dicono:
“Non metterti la pianta in camera”.
Ogni volta che dico sta cosa,
tutti dicono sì, che  le nonne insistono
che non si mettono le piante in camera,
perché le piante di notte respirano,
quindi emettono anidride carbonica
come facciamo noi,
ma anche di giorno lo fanno.
Questi due processi sono antagonisti.
Con la fotosintesi l’anidride carbonica
viene incamerata nel sistema,
con la respirazione
viene emessa dal sistema.
Poi ci sono le altre
componenti dell’ecosistema.
Tantissimi decompositori
che stanno nel suolo,
ce ne sono tantissimi,
che degradano la sostanza organica
e quindi emettono anidride carbonica,
e ovviamente tutti gli altri eterotrofi
che sono gli erbivori, i carnivori, ecc.
che anche loro come noi
emettono anidride carbonica.
Quindi vedete, ci sono
dei processi di assorbimento
e dei processi che portano
all’emissione di anidride carbonica
in un sistema complesso come la foresta.
La domanda fondamentale
per rispondere alle questioni di prima è:
qual è il bilancio tra questi
due processi, complessivamente.
Quant’è la quantità di anidride carbonica
che va dentro con la fotosintesi,
nel sistema,
e quant’è la quantità
di anidride carbonica che va fuori,
con la respirazione
di tutte le componenti del sistema,
suolo, piante, animali, ecc.
Vi propongo due scenari,
due casi tipici, diciamo.
Le foreste naturali,
che sono quelle primarie,
dove l’uomo non è ancora intervenuto.
Esistono ancora fortunatamente,
non in Italia, pochissime in Europa.
Ce ne sono, ad esempio, in Siberia,
dove ci sono migliaia di chilometri
senza una strada
e ovviamente l’uomo
non riesce a tagliare lì,
o anche nelle foreste pluviali tropicali
ci sono ancora foreste primarie.
Le foreste primarie come si comportano?
Poi ci sono le foreste coltivate.
Le foreste primarie.
Ecco un esempio di foresta primaria,
questa è sui Carpazi,
dove ci sono ancora
delle riserve molto belle.
Vedete quanti tronchi a terra ci sono,
perché non c’è nessuno
che estrae il legno e lo porta via.
Gli alberi cadono e si degradano.
Bellissima complessità,
tanto legno morto a terra.
E qui è una foresta pluviale in Costarica,
dove si vede proprio
la copertura molto densa,
perché la foresta naturale arriva
a una condizione di massima complessità,
di massima densità,
più densa di così non si può.
Come funziona una foresta naturale?
La foresta naturale
funziona più o meno così:
a seguito di un disturbo,
ad esempio vi ricordate gli eventi Vaia,
sono state abbattute le foreste.
Dopo che le foreste vengono abbattute,
naturalmente ricrescono,
senza bisogno dell’uomo, lo fanno da sole.
Ricrescono e, nel tempo,
aumenta la complessità,
aumenta la massa, crescono.
Questa è la curva
della biomassa complessiva.
Aumentano fino a quando?
Fino a quando riescono a usare
tutte le risorse disponibili.
Ad esempio, tutta l’acqua che ha
a disposizione in quel particolare luogo.
Non crescono indefinitivamente.
Nessun sistema biologico
cresce per sempre.
Perché siccome le risorse sono finite,
l’acqua è finita, l’azoto è finito,
la crescita non può essere infinita.
Quindi i sistemi naturali raggiungono
un equilibrio di massa
che viene realizzato quando usano
tutte le risorse al meglio,
le risorse disponibili
per quel particolare sito.
In questa condizione di equilibrio
com’è il flusso di anidride carbonica?
Questo è il punto.
Eccolo qui, lo vediamo:
qui la foresta è giovane.
Passa il tempo, anni, secoli.
Questa è la foresta vetusta.
Qui vediamo la variazione della massa,
che cresce e poi a un certo punto
resta abbastanza stabile.
E qui i due processi
di cui parlavamo prima.
Fotosintesi,
questa linea qui;
e respirazione complessiva del sistema,
questa linea qua.
Quando la foresta è giovane
ovviamente la fotosintesi domina,
è molto più grande,
ed è giusto che sia così
perché se del carbonio
viene incamerato nel sistema,
vuol dire che i processi di ingresso,
di incameramento della CO2,
sono superiori a quelli di emissioni.
Il sistema cresce
perché il carbonio dall’atmosfera
deve essere immesso nel sistema,
e ne esce di meno di quello che entra,
per cui la comunità nel complesso cresce.
Ma andando avanti
l’evoluzione della foresta,
si arriva a un punto di equilibrio
di massa, come abbiamo detto prima.
In questo punto di equilibrio
di massa, ovviamente,
i due processi di entrata
e uscita si equivalgono.
È come se avessi una vasca da bagno
con un livello di acqua sempre costante,
vuol dire che l’entrata
e l’uscita sono uguali.
Quindi in questa situazione
i flussi sono grandissimi,
perché è grandissima la fotosintesi,
è grandissima la respirazione,
ma quantitativamente sono simili
e quindi si compensano.
Il risultato è che,
contrariamente a quanto uno può pensare,
leggiamo solo l’ultima frase
di un articolo di Nature che dice
che nel complesso le foreste
amazzoniche e le altre foreste tropicali
sono in una condizione
di equilibrio della CO2.
Se sono in una condizione
di equilibrio della CO2,
il concetto che le foreste tropicali
siano polmoni verdi,
cioè che assorbono carbonio,
diventa un po’ meno consistente.
Certamente le foreste
hanno degli andamenti di massa
che non sono proprio stabili,
quindi possono calare e crescere,
c’è una certa oscillazione.
Però, sinceramente,
non dovrei attendermi –
e questo è dimostrato
anche da questo grafico qui –
non dovrei attendermi
un grande flusso di CO2.
Questo è un articolo recentissimo
di Nature, una rivista importante.
Queste sono le foreste tropicali.
Qui è lo zero, l’equilibrio
di anidride carbonica,
e vedete che siamo qua.
Vedete quanto vicini siamo allo zero.
Queste sono le foreste pluviali,
queste le africane, ma non ne parliamo,
queste sono quelle tropicali
dell’Amazzonia.
I ricercatori prevedono
addirittura che nel 2035
la foresta diventi emettitore di carbonio.
Quindi dal concetto
di foresta polmone verde
mi ritrovo il concetto di foresta
che addirittura aumenta l’effetto serra,
perché emette più carbonio
di quello che assorbe.
E questo è dovuto al fatto
che con i cambiamenti climatici
le condizioni di temperatura sono
più severe per le piante, piove meno
e quindi gli alberi alti
cominciano a morire,
gli alberi più grandi delle foreste
pluviali cominciano a morire.
Sono stati riportati fenomeni di mortalità
diffusa nelle foreste tropicali
molto significativi
degli alberi più grandi.
Se gli alberi più grandi muoiono,
la respirazione complessiva
del sistema aumenta,
perché le foglie diminuiscono
e viene degradata quella massa.
Quindi,
le foreste pluviali naturali
non dovrebbero essere molto attive
nell’assorbire il carbonio,
non ci danno tanto una mano, diciamo.
Vediamo le foreste coltivate.
Allora, sulle foreste coltivate
una cosa devo dire,
perchè sono ecologo forestale.
Le foreste non hanno bisogno di noi.
Se ne stanno benissimo da sole.
Siamo noi che abbiamo
bisogno delle foreste.
Quindi non è vero che una foresta
senza l’uomo si degrada.
Bugia.
Non ha senso.
Le foreste stanno benissimo da sole.
Infatti ai nostri studenti diciamo sempre:
“Quando entrate a gestire una foresta –
perché noi forestali gestiamo le foreste –
entrate in punta di piedi”,
perché è un sistema
comunque che tu perturbi.
Puoi perturbarlo
tanto o poco, bene o male,
ma perturbi un sistema
che se ne starebbe benissimo da solo.
Questo è importante,
perché si sentono dire tante cose,
che le foreste senza di noi scompaiono...
Non ha senso.
Com’è che l’uomo gestisce le foreste?
Nel migliore dei modi le gestisce
con quella che viene chiamata
la gestione forestale sostenibile.
Cos’è la gestione forestale sostenibile
e come si attua.
È semplicissimo.
È come avere un conto in banca.
Il capitale mi dà
un certo interesse annuo,
spendo solo l’interesse
e mantengo il capitale
fruttante per sempre.
Molto semplice.
Le foreste sono ecosistemi
che si auto rigenerano.
Tutti noi abbiamo l’esperienza
del papà e la mamma
che ci portavanoda piccoli a contare
quanti anni aveva l’albero su una ceppaia
e c’erano i famosi anelli legnosi.
Quello è l’interesse annuale.
Ogni anno la pianta cresce
di quella quantità lì, si rigenera.
Io accumulo tutto l’interesse
dato dalla foresta e lo porto via.
In un certo periodo, 10 anni ad esempio,
accumulo un interesse per 10 anni
e ogni 10 anni entro una foresta,
taglio quello che la foresta
ha dato come interesse
e mantengo il capitale fruttante costante.
Eccolo qui.
Taglio e la foresta ricresce,
taglio e la foresta ricreste.
Gestione forestale sostenibile,
si può fare per sempre.
In questo caso, con massa costante,
come con la massa costante
delle foreste pluviali
non c’era assorbimento di carbonio,
anche qui, se la massa è costante
la foresta non assorbe carbonio.
Prendo del legno, lo porto fuori,
e dopo di questo legno che è fuori foresta
eventualmente ne parleremo,
ma, in foresta, non c’è
un assorbimento netto di carbonio.
Qui vedete altre due curve.
Una gestione non sostenibile,
cioè taglio molto di più
di quello che è l’incremento periodico,
l’interesse del capitale.
Quindi taglio 10 e la foresta ricresce 1,
poi taglio 10 e la foresta ricresce 1.
Ovviamente depaupero il capitale.
Gestione non sostenibile.
È quello che stiamo facendo,
ad esempio, con i grandi pesci predatori.
Raccogliamo molto di più della capacità
della popolazione dei tonni di rigenerarsi
e quindi la popolazione
purtroppo sta diminuendo.
E questo: Vaia.
È come un’inflazione brutale.
Perdiamo tutto il capitale.
E dobbiamo aspettare
che il capitale si ricostituisca,
ci vuole un secolo o due.
Quali sono le foreste
che assorbono carbonio?
Le foreste che assorbono carbonio
sono quelle che crescono.
Questo è un esempio di foresta
che assorbe carbonio.
Massa che cresce, taglio meno
dell’incremento, meno dell’interesse,
porto via meno dell’interesse.
Quindi l’interesse residuo
si cumula al capitale.
Il capitale aumenta.
Quindi supponiamo: 1000 euro in banca
mi danno 100 euro di interesse,
ne spendo solo 50.
L’anno dopo ho 1050 euro
che mi danno un interesse maggiore,
ne spendo meno e così cumulo.
Se la massa della foresta aumenta,
vuol dire che la CO2 dall’atmosfera
si è trasferita in questa massa.
Quindi ho fatto un’opera di assorbimento
netto di anidride carbonica,
solo se la foresta cresce.
Però, se lascio la foresta crescere,
posso ottenere meno legno,
perché o faccio crescere la foresta
oppure utilizzo l’interesse.
Quindi vedete che sono due attività
che sono in contrasto tra loro,
e devo decidere
se farne una o se fare l’altra
o se fare parzialmente l’una e l’altra.
Facciamo degli esempi,
quantitativamente quanto può essere
questo processo di crescita.
Questa è un’iniziativa
di cui forse avete sentito parlare,
“60 milioni di alberi”, molto bella.
Ovviamente sono forestale, non potrei dire
che piantare alberi è una cosa negativa.
Piantare gli alberi va sempre bene,
quindi benissimo piantare gli alberi.
Però, per capire
quanto questa iniziativa faccia
rispetto alle nostre emissioni
di CO2 a livello di comunità,
se piantiamo un albero a testa,
che è un impegno già consistente,
potremmo assorbire lo 0,5 per cento
delle nostre emissioni.
Che non è tanto.
Allora, se facciamo un calcolo al giorno,
per avere un’idea
di qual è il nostro impatto,
emettiamo circa 20 chili
di anidride carbonica al giorno,
mediamente noi italiani.
Un albero ne assorbe circa 100 grammi.
Allora, 20 chili contro 100 grammi.
Siamo su un altro ordine di grandezza.
Scaliamo a livello nazionale.
Così, sempre per fare due conti semplici.
Per assorbire tutte le emissioni
di ognuno di noi,
ciascuno avrebbe bisogno di una superficie
di circa un ettaro e mezzo,
che sono circa due campi da calcio.
Quindi vuol dire avere
a disposizione 90 milioni di ettari,
che sono tre volte l’Italia,
perché l’Italia è 30 milioni di ettari.
Quindi servono tre Italie da piantare
per assorbire le nostre emissioni.
Il problema è che le devo
lasciare lì che crescano.
Ma purtroppo le foreste
hanno un altro problema:
la cosiddetta non permanenza.
Cioè ci sono tanti eventi di disturbo,
che distruggono il nostro capitale,
Vaia oppure gli incendi.
Gli incendi boschivi sono
un problema serissimo.
Ad esempio, questa è un’immagine
di qualche anno fa in Siberia.
Forse qualcuno ha sentito degli incendi
in California, in Australia, fortissimi,
sempre più gravi peraltro.
Bruciati in pochi mesi
7 milioni di ettari.
La superficie forestale italiana
è 10 milioni di ettari.
Praticamente ha bruciato
tutta la superficie,
in pochi mesi tutta
la superficie forestale italiana,
con un’emissione pari a tre volte quello
che gli italiani emettono in un anno,
tutti gli italiani emettono in un anno.
Quindi il problema è: affido alle foreste
l’assorbimento di carbonio,
però poi ci può essere
un evento di disturbo critico,
che letteralmente mi manda in fumo
quello che ho fatto per 50, 60, 70 anni.
Veniamo a cosa si può fare altrimenti.
Forse avete capito che sono veneziano.
Sono venuto in treno,
oggi ho deciso di venire in treno.
Potevo venire anche in auto, però no!
Anche se magari faccio tardi,
perdo il treno
e mi tocca aspettare un’ora,
perché ce n’è uno all’ora per Venezia.
Però non importa,
ho deciso di venire in treno.
Se venivo in macchina emettevo
circa 10 chili di anidride carbonica,
andata e ritorno.
Sono venuto in treno.
Con il treno si consuma un decimo circa,
rispetto al viaggiatore singolo.
Quindi ho risparmiato 9 chili.
Semplicemente con la mia scelta,
vengo in treno anziché in auto,
ho risparmiato 9 chili
di anidride carbonica in atmosfera.
Se avessi un albero solo per me,
che assorbe le mie emissioni,
impiegherebbe un anno per assorbire
questi 9 chili di anidride carbonica.
Se ne pianto uno piccolo con poche foglie,
quindi cresce poco, poverello,
ci vogliono quattro anni.
La differenza di tempo
tra una scelta di riduzione
e usare le foreste per assorbire.
Spero sia chiaro.
Bene, quindi, vado alla conclusione.
Le foreste assorbono
anidride carbonica solo se crescono.
Quindi devono avere un aumento di massa.
Quindi, siccome le foreste naturali sono
in una condizione di equilibrio,
non dovrebbero avere
grande effetto di assorbimento.
Quindi non possiamo tanto contare
sulle foreste naturali
per assorbire la CO2.
Quindi, polmoni verdi:
concetto un po’ in discussione.
Il ruolo delle foreste
può essere naturalmente positivo,
perché un po’ di carbonio lo assorbono,
se le lascio crescere,
ma sicuramente non è risolutivo.
La cosa grave è che certi messaggi
potrebbero farci distrarre
dalle azioni importanti,
che sono quelle di riduzione.
Allora, se passa il messaggio
“pianto un albero e poi vado
a fare la spesa col SUV”,
allora no, non va bene.
Pianta l’albero e vai in bicicletta
a fare la spesa.
È molto più efficace in termini
di riduzione delle emissioni.
Qui faccio sempre la scenetta
perché è interessante.
Immagina una foresta
e un uomo che si parlano
e la foresta dice all’uomo:
“Mi hai chiesto di darti il legno
per costruirti le case,
ti ho dato il legno
per costruirti le case”,
“Mi hai chiesto di darti il legno
per cucinare le pietanze,
ti ho dato il legno
per cucinare le pietanze”.
Un terzo della popolazione mondiale
ha ancora bisogno del legno per cucinare,
un terzo della popolazione mondiale.
Ok.
“Mi hai chiesto di difenderti
dalle valanghe,
ti ho difeso dalle valanghe.”
“Mi hai chiesto di difenderti dalle frane,
ti ho difeso dalle frane.”
“Mi hai chiesto
di tutelare la biodiversità” –
perché le foreste sono l’ambiente
terrestre più ricco di biodiversità –
“ti ho tutelato la biodiversità.”
“Mi hai chiesto di renderti
le città belle, più fresche,
dove tu puoi passeggiare,
stare in pace con te stesso e rilassarti;
ti ho dato le città con gli alberi, ecc.”
“Adesso mi chiedi anche
di assorbire la CO2?”
“Fai qualcosa anche tu però, per piacere.”
Grazie.
(Applausi)